[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ما في حصاد الليله معكم في دب
اسيل وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
واحداث وتتفاعل اخرى في السياسه ايجاز
المرتب في واشنطن للبيت الابيض يتضمن
التعليق على عدد من القضايا
وسجالات عالميا
ولكن العيون تتجه اكثر هذه الايام الى
منافسات الرياضه في مونديال قطر هذا استاد
لوسيل يستضيف واحده من المنافسات المصريه
التي تهم العرب بين المنتخب السعودي
والمنتخب المكسيكي
اما هذه اللقطات فتاتين من بونيس ايرس حيث
تتابع الجماهير المباراه المصيريه الاخرى
بين منتخبي الارجنتين وبولندا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
مع استمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا واشنط تقول
انه موسكو دمرت الثلث البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه ومقترح اوروبي يقضي بمصادره
الاصول الروسيه المجمده لتمويل عمليات
اعاده الاعمار
المناسبه وتقول ان مرافق البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه الاوكرانيه استخدمت في دعم
العمليات العسكريه
تركيا
شمال سوريا
عدم تهديد العمليه لعمل القوات الامريكيه
وروسيا
بوادر سباق تسلح النووي تدخل على خط
المنافسه بين الاقطاب البنتاجون يرجع
ارتفاعا مخزون الصيني من الرؤوس النوويه
باكثر من ثلاثه اضعاف بحلول العام 2035
بيجين تنفي انخراطها في اي سباق للتسلح
وتؤكد التزامها بعدم البدء باستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه وما دعوتها لتجنب مواجهه
النوويه موسكو تقول انها ستول اهتماما
خاصا ببناء بنيه تحتيه ترتبط بقوتها
النوويه
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الجدل والمخاوف المتعلقه
بسياسه منصه تويتر في مراقبه المحتوى حيث
برزت انباء بان اداره الشركه اوقفت مثلا
مراقبه المحتوى المتعلق بالاخبار المغلوطه
المتعلقه بكوفيد نايتين او كوفيت 19 وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه طالبت الشركه بضروره
اخضاع المحتوى للرقابه والاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي هل سيساهم الجدل والضغط في
تشديده منصه تويتر سياسه مراقبه المحتوى
واحد وخمسين او 51 في المئه صوتوا بنعم
ونحو 48 صوتوا بلاه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت
عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصه الرقميه يتجدد يوميا و
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
منتخب وتونس يتغلب على نظيره الفرنسيه
حامل اللقب ويغادر البطوله واستراليا
ترافق فرنسا للدور الثاني بفوزها على
الدنمارك
وبعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في الساعه
الثانيه عشره وخمس دقائق بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه تتابعون الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه
يوميات المونديال التي ترصد بالخبر
والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم قطر 2022
قال وزير الخارجات الامريكيه انطوني بنكن
ان الرئيس الروسي دمر ثلث البنيه التحتيه
في اوكرانيا وعرضت رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ارسلافندر لاين مقترحا لمصادره
الاصول الروسيه المجمده لتمويل اعاده
اعمار اوكرانيا في المقابل قالت وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ان موسكو ستتخذ ما
وصفتها باجراءات المناسبه اذا تعلق الامر
بمصادره اصولها في الاتحاد الاوروبي
يتجدد الحديث عن اعمار اوكرانيا بعد تسعه
اشهر من الحرب تتهم روسيا خلال تلك الفتره
بعدم تحقيق شيء سوى استهداف المدنيين
ومرافقهم الحيويه وخاصه خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه التي تكرر فيها قصف محطات كهرباء
وبنا تحتيه تتعاظم الحاجه لسلامتها مع بدا
الشتاء وفقا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطونيو بلانكن دمرت روسيا الثلث البنيه
التحتيه في اوكرانيا وتشمل القطاعات
المدمره شبكات المياه والصرف الصحي
والكهرباء بحسب تصريحات سابقه لرئيس
مجموعه البنك الدولي ديفيد معلباس كم تبلغ
كلفه اعاده الاعمار في اوكرانيا تزامنا مع
تصريحات لينكن تحدثت رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ارسولافندر لاين عندما يقدر ب
600 مليار يورو مطالبه روسيا بتحمل
فاتورته
فظيعه بما في ذلك جرائمها ضد دوله ذات
سياده وعلى روسيا كذلك دفع تعويضات ماديه
جراء الدمار الذي تسببت فيه
الطريق الى ذلك وفق الاتحاد الاوروبي ياتي
عبر توظيف الاموال الروسيه المجمده في
عمليات اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا وهي ليست
المره الاولى التي يطالب فيها الاتحاد
الاوروبي بذلك موسكو من جهتها توعدت
باتخاد ما وصفتها باجراءات مناسبه اذا
تعلق الامر بمصادره اصولها في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وفقا لتقديرات اوروبيه يبلغ
اجمالي الاصول الروسيه الخاصه المجمده في
الاتحاد ضمن العقوبات حوالي 19 مليار يورو
لا يمكن قانونيا مصادره تلك الاموال
المجمده الا في حال وجود ادانه جنائيه لعل
هذا ما يفسر تاكيد رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه على ضروره انشاء محكمه خاصه
مدعومه الامميه للتحقيق وملاحقه روسيا لكن
هذا المسار المقترح لم يسمح بالتصرف في
اموال روسيا المجمده قبل سنوات من التقاضي
البحث عن تصوير قانوني للتصرف في الاموال
الروسيه المجمده يشغل الاوروبيين منذ
الشهور الاولى للحرب لعله الفزع من تحميل
الاقتصاد الاوروبي المثقل اعباء اضافيه في
سبتمبر الماضي اكد تقرير اوروبي اوكراني
مشترك ان مئه وخمسه مليارات دولار مطلوبه
على مدار السنوات الثلاث القادمه لتلبيه
الاحتياجات العاجله وقدر حينها رئيس
الوزراء الاوكراني كلفه المرحله الاولى من
اعاده الاعمار بنحو 17 مليار دولار يجب
توفير اكثر من ثلاثه مليارات منها هذا
العام وكان وزير الماليه الاوكراني قد اكد
قبل اشهر حاجه بلاده الى خمسه مليارات
دولار شهريا لضمان استمرار دوران عجلتها
الاقتص يا وسط الحرب فماذا تفعل اوروبا
اذاعه تلك الارقام لاحلى سوى البحث عن
مقترحات تشريعيه تسوق توظيف المال الروسي
المجمد او ما سماه مسؤولون اوروبيون من
قبل كنز بوتين لجهه اعمار ما دمرته قواته
في اوكرانيا في هذا السياق يمتد النظر
الاوروبي ايضا الى حوالي 300 مليار يورو
من اصول البنك المركزي الروسي المجمده لكن
الحواجز القانونيه دونها اعقد بحكم كونها
مشموله بحصانه الدوله الروسيه حتى وان
عجزت موسكو عن التصرف فيها حاليا بسبب
العقوبات يبدو الطريق نحو اعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا محفوفا بالجدل والصعوبات التي قد
تقلص من حجم وعود التضامن الاوروبيه
حضر مدير منع الانتشار والسيطره على
الاسلحه في الخارجيه الروسيه فلاديمير
يرماكوف من ان الاقمار الصناعيه شبه
المدنيه المستخدمه في اوكرانيا يمكن ان
تصبح هدفا مشروعا للقوات الروسيه وقال
يرمكاف ان الغربه يستخدم بنشاط امكانات
البنيه التحتيه الفضائيه المدنيه من اجل
دعم العمليات الاوكرانيه واضاف ان
استخدامها هذه الامكانات المدنيه لتنفيذ
مهام قتاليه محدده للكشف عن المواقع
ومسارات تحركاته واعمال القوات الروسيه
والتحكم في المسيارات وتوجيه الاسلحه
الموجهه بدقه واشار ايار مكاف الى ان ما
سماه لاستخدام الاستفزازي للاقمار
الصناعيه المدنيه يثيره تساؤلات في سياقه
معاهده الفضاء الخارجي والتي تعني استخدام
السلمي فقط كما يتطلب اشد الادانه من قبل
المجتمع الدولي
ينضم الينا من بيروت لويس من جانب وينو
المتحدث باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي ومن موسكو
يبكيني عضو مجلس الدوله الروسيه
عن ليس فقط تجميد الاصول بالاستخدام هذه
الاصول في اعاده الاعمار واعاده اعمار
بنيت تحتيه للطاقه بالتحديد ما مدى
الاجماع داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي حول ذلك
مساء الخير
القمه الاوروبيه
السابقه
اقترحت المفاضله الاوروبيه اليوم من خلال
رئيسها
رئيس البونتر لاين استراحه جديده حول هذا
الموضوع انه هو واضح يعني والحدث وهو
محاسبه مرتكبيه هذه الجرائم هذه الحركه
الدمويه
وما يحصل عليهم في اوكرانيا من الجرائم
ملكه موافقه من قبل الجميع الدول
الاوروبيه كندا كانت تحدثت عن الموضوع
الولايات المتحده وهي خارج الاتحاد
الاوروبي كانت ايضا اشارت الى هذا الموضوع
بريطانيا وهي خارج الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا
كانت تبحث عن اليه قانونيه ولكن اليوم
عندما تتحدث رئيسه المفوضيه هل يعني ذلك
ان هنالك موافقه من جميع اعضاء الاتحاد
هو همم نتيجه طلب من قبل الدول في الاتحاد
همم
الكوره في ملعب على مستوى وزاره
التدخل في التفاصيل هذه
الاقتراحات
الرسول ايضا مصادر القانون الاوروبي همم
لابد ان اقول بان الفكره هي اداره هذه
الاصول او انشاء
الدوليه واستخدام هذه الاصول للسائح التي
مج
رفع العقود مباراه المقصود على الروسيا
سيكون هناك ربما اتفاقيه بين طرفين وجزء
مهم هذا اتفاقيه اذا كنت تعويذات الحرب
والفكره انه نستخدم احتياطيات البنك
المركزي الروسي بهذا السبب ساعود الى هذه
الاليه ولكن دعني اسمع من السيد
افديني سيد افجيني وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
تهدد ان موسكو ستتخذ ما وصفتها باجراءات
مناسبه في هذه الحاله ما هي هذه الاجراءات
المناسبه
ان تصل هذه الاموال الاسواق العالميه لانه
ليس المهم الاموال بل اي همم بضائع ممكن
ان تشترى اعتقد ان ليس هناك اي بضائع في
اوروبا ممكن ان تشترى هذا اولا الشيء
الثاني سوف نقوم بتصدير كل الممتلكات
الاجنبيه التابعه لامريكا واوروبا
المتواجده على
روسيا وهذه الممتلكات تبلغ من الاموال
اكثر بكثير من المبالغ التي تجمدت هذا
الحل يتناسب معنا تماما يجب عليهم
اوروبا همم لديها مستوى معيش عالي جدا
بطريقه غير عادي
لديها علاقات غير عادل مع روسيا والصين
والدول العربيه وهذا قيل في السابق ان
انا اوروبا تشتري البضائع الرخيصه من
روسيا والعماله الرخيصه من الصين
الممتلكات الاجنبيه التي ستصادرها روسيا
هل لديك اي ارقام تقول بانها اكثر بكثير
من ما ستجمده او يجمده الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده
البنك المركزي هذه القرن تصل الى همم 500
مليار دولار موجود في
روسيا هذه اموال الامريكيه واوروبيه وهذه
الارقام موجوده في البنك العالمي
وهذا رقم رسمي
مره جديده اليك سيد لويس سيد لويس ان كنت
قد اشارت الى الاليه انشاء الصندوق من اجل
الاستثمار هذه الاموال واعاده استخدامها
لكن هل هنالك بني قانونيه تسمح للدول
الاوروبيه بالقيام بذلك وماذا عن
مستقيمتها
طبعا الالبوم القانونيه والبنيه تحتيها
القانونيه ستكون موجوده لانه الامن يعني
مثل ما مسحتنا خلال شهور الماضيه ان
التسارعت الاجراءات مرتبطه بما يحدث في
اوكرانيا داخله لاتحاد الاوروبي والرغم
البروكراتي الفقيره همم في الاتحاد بشكل
واضح وانا احنا متاكدين بانه متاكدون بان
هذا الامر همم يعني سيكون ليس فقط على
الطاوله المفضلات بين الدول وانما هناك
اجماع واضح حول يعني ضروره ضروره ايجاد
حلول او طرق قانونيه مناسبه للقيام بذلك
وادعوني انا اقول لك بان همم الاجتماع
موجود بالفعل يعني والفكره منطقيه لانه
تتحمل روسيا كامل مسئوليه ما يحصل في
اوكرانيا يعني من سنه هذه الحرب من من
اللي
كان مستقيم الاسود اعود اليك سيد همم
اذا تحدثنا عن الشركات على سبيل المثال
الشركات الاجنبيه ولكن ليس كلها اجنبيه بل
هناك شركاء روس هل ستجمدون اصولها هؤلاء
هل ستمنعون عن هؤلاء اموالهم
يعني اليست العمليه معقده
نعم في الكثير من الشركات هناك القروض
الاجنبيه ومثل هذا موجود في غاز فروم
والنفط وشركات النفط والشوف نقوم بتجميد
كل الاجزاء الاجنبيه ليس الاستثمارات بل
القروض ايضا هذه الارقام اعلى بكثير من
الارقام الموجوده في اوروبا
ليس هناك احد في الاتحاد الاوروبي يمكن ان
يسمح لنا او يمنعنا مما نقوم به في
روسيا ليس هناك اي ارض تسمى اوكرانيا نحن
نقوم بحرب على مناطق ظهرت على الخريطه
بطريقه غير قانونيه بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
باختصار لو سمحت
سوف سوف
ايقاف الاموال ذات المصادر الاجنبيه فقط
سواء كانت اوروبيه او امريكا والارقام
اعلى بكثير من الارقام التي جمدت في
اوروبا وهنا نتحدث عن الاحتياط الموجود في
روسيا
ذات المصادر الاوروبيه والمتواجده على
الاراضي الروسيه بغض النظر عن من يقود هذه
الشركات رسميه في روسيا الكثير من من يعيش
في لندن حتى وان كانوا رؤوسا هم ليس مواطن
روسيا الواقع لذلك همم مصادره هذه الاموال
سوف تساعدنا على تجديد العلاقات الماليه
مع اوروبيه ما سوف يقوي الاقتصاد الروسي
وهذا سوف يعدل التعقيدات في العلاقات
الاقتصاديه سوف يحدد من يمتلك ماذا
مجلس الدماء
مجال بوينو على المتحدث باسم الاتحاد
الاوروبي
وبالعوده الى الاجتماعات النت وفي بخارست
قال الامين العام لحلفي شمال الاطلسيه
تمثل خطرا مباشرا على امن الحلف وفي مؤتمر
صحفي على هامش اجتماعات وزراء خارجيه
الحلف في بوخارست اكد اسفلتمبرغ على
استمرار الدعم اوكانيا اضافيه
مع المانيا سبل تزويد اوكرانيا بمنظومه
صواريخ باتريوت الامريكيه واضافه في مؤتمر
صحفيه على هامش اجتماعات وزراء خارجيه
الانترنت في رومانيا ان اوكرانيا بحاجه
لهذه الصواريخ لحمايه البنيه الاساسيه
المدنيه واكد كلباء على ضروره بدء محادثات
انضمام اوكرانيا الى النيته كما طالبه
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني بتزويد بلاده
بدبابات الغربيه في اسرع وقت ممكن
ومن موسكو رده متحدثته باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريه زخروف فرات فان نتائج لقاء
وزراء خارجيه الناتو في بوخارست تشير الى
ان الحلف غيره مهتم بحل سياسيا ودبلوماسيا
للاوضاع في اوكرانيا واتهمت زى خروف
الناتو بمواصله نهجه لشيطنه روسيا وتبرئه
كيف من جرائمها لتبرير بقائه بحسب تعبيرها
افاد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
بانفجار عبوه ناسفه كانت مخبا داخل سفاره
اوكرانيا في مدريد اسفر عن جرح موظفا
واضاف المتحدث ان وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه اصدر تعليمات لتعزيز امن جميع
سفارات بلاده
[موسيقى]
اكد مصدر رسمي تركيه للجزيره اكتمال
تحضيرات لعمليه عسكريه بريه الشمالي سوريا
وقال ان العمليه لن تهدد القوات الامريكيه
او الروسيه واكد المصدر رفض انقر لانتشار
الشكلي لقوات النظام السوري في مناطق ما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه من جهه اخرى
في تركيا
ما عدا السؤال هل بل متى فعلى خط النار
تلتهب واحتمالات وتنفيذ الاتراك عمليه
عسكريه بريه في الشمال السوري
لا تخفي مصادر رسميه تركيه اكتمال ما تقول
انها تحضيرات العسكريه واللوجستيه اللازمه
لتنفيذ تلك العمليه
حتى تحين اللحظه يكثف الجيش التركي
شعبا ودوله والحمد لله قادرون على مكافحه
الارهاب في شمال سوريا كما قمنا بذلك في
سوريا وفي العراق وفي اي مكان اخر في
العالم ورغم ان بعض الحلفاء يقدمون
تصريحات تدعمون في شمال سوريا فانهم
يطلبون منا امورا لا يمكن قوله لها ليست
هواجس الحلفاء اي وحدهم فالقلق غالب على
المواقف الدوليه من خطوه تركيه قد تعرض
الاستقرار الاقليميه للخطر هنا يطمئن
الاتراك بان عملياتهم العسكريه تنفذ بشكل
دقيق ضد وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه في
شمال سوريا ومن دون اي تهديد
سلامه القوات الامريكيه والروسيه
يخشى الامريكيون مع ذلك من ان اجتياح
باليا سيبدل ماء الجزاء في قتال تنظيم
الدوله
لكنهم يبدون التفاهم لما خاوي في تركيا
الامنيه حيال الاعمال الارهابيه داخل
حدودها
المساله برمتها يكشف البنتاجون ان وزير
الدفاع لويد اوستن سيبحثها هاتفا عما قريب
مع نظيره التركي خلص يا اكار لكن اين
الروس من كل ذلك
صحيح ان الجدل انتعش حول مدى التزامهم
باتفاقيه سوتشي لكنهم دخلوا على خط الازمه
المستجده لمحاوله احتوائها يبدو ان موسكو
سمعت من انقار اشتراطاتها للعدول عن
العمليه العسكريه البريه في الشمال السوري
واضح ان الاتراك لن يرضوا باقل من حل
الوحدات الكرديه او اخراجها من مناطق
النفوذ الروسي ووقف محاولتها للتسلل الى
تركيا على ان تعود مؤسسات النظام السوري
بما فيها القوات الامريكيه وحرس الحدود
بديلا عما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
سيشكل ذلك كله تحديا لمساعد الروس لتهدئه
الاوضاع فاي عرض سيقدمونه ينبغي ان يلبي
مطالبه تركيا
ينضم الينا من واشنطن
كبير الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي
والمختص في الشؤون التركيه وينضم الينا من
انقره ايضا نورهان الدبلوماسيه التركيه
السابق سيد ايدون ابدا مع كمال محدد
للانطلاق هذه العمليه البريه من عدمه هل
تحيد وتخليص قدره ما يعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه كافن ام انه لابد من ابعادها
الى ما بعد الحدود التركيه بنسبه 30 كلم
كيكي
مصممه على دفع هؤلاء الارهابيين
الا بعد ان يصل الى 30 كلم
الامريكان وعدو تركيا قبل وقت طويل بانهم
سيقومون بدفعها هؤلاء الارهابيين بعيدا عن
الحدود التركيه
ممكن هذا الامر لم يحصل
والاولاد المتحده وروسيا تحاول ان تقول
لحزب العمال انا اا اخوكم الاكبر الحقيقي
بالتالي لم يقم اي طرف من الاطراف لم
يتوقفوا عن اللعب مع حزب العمال
[موسيقى]
سوريا
على ايران والعراق الولايات المتحده تريد
ان تؤسس لكيان كرديه في سوريا هم يريد ان
يقسموا سوريا
سيد اعلن اذا وعدتم ولم تفهم بوعودكم
خيارات التي ابقيتموها امام تركيا من جهه
تقولون بانكم او الولايات المتحده تقول
بانها تاخذ بعين الاعتبار المخاوف التركيه
ولكنها تخشى من انعكاس ذلك على محاربه
تنظيم الدوله
مع روسيا والولايات المتحده بشكل منفصل
هذا ما قامت به تركيا هذه الاتفاق حياد
حسب علمي تم تطبيقها
لكن اذا ما كانت المشكله متمثله لانها لم
يتم تطبيقها بشكل كاف وكامل يجب ان يكون
هذا نقطه التركيز لدى تركيا الجهد
الدبلوماسيه من اجل اما ان يتم تحسين
تطبيق هذه شروط هذه الاتفاقيات او ان
ربما يكون هنالك تغيير في شروط الاتفاقيات
بشكل طبيعي لكن يجب ان يتم القيام بذلك عن
طريق الجهد الدوسي ليس هناك حاجه الى
التدخل العسكري وكما قال وكما قلت شكل
وانت محق بذلك اذا ما كانت هنالك عملي
عسكريه
سيؤثر هذا الامر على الحرب الغده تنظيم
الدوله هنالك ما يزال الالاف من مقاتلي من
لتنظيم الدوله منتشره هنا في المنطقه واي
غزو تركي ان قوى سوريا الديمقراطيه عليها
ان تركزه على مواجهه القوات التركيه بدلا
من مواجهه مقاتلي تنظيم الدوله وايضا ارغب
بالقول
كان امي معك
زميلي من تركيا هو ليس محاق ان الولايات
المتحده لا تحاول ان تؤسس او تدعم تاسيس
دوله تركيا او كان تركي عفانه في سوريا ان
نحن نعمل مع قوات سوريا ديمقراطيه وهذا حق
صحيح التي تقودها المجموعات الكرديه لكن
هذا هو هدفنا الاساسي هدفنا الوحيد
والاساسي ومقاتله تنظيم الدوله عن طريق
التعاون مع قوى سوريا الديمقراطيه
بان ما تقوم به تركيا قد يعزز وجود تنظيم
الدوله او يؤثر على الحرب من قلب ما
تقولها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
تعليقها على هذه العمليه اعود اليك مره
جديده سيد ايضا سيد ايضا لماذا لا يتم
استخدام الوسائل الدبلوماسيه لماذا اللجوء
الى عمليه عسكريه هذا ما يسال عنه السيد
علي
ان الغزو كلمه غاز وتعبير غاز وهو ليس
تعبير دقيق وتركيا لا تريد ان تغزو اي بلد
نحن نقوم بالدفاع عن انفسنا هذا امر اساسي
[موسيقى]
حزب العمال
قنابل تضرب وتستهدف تركيا
في سوريا او في العراق
الكثير من الجنود في قتالنا مع داعش نحن
واجهناهم ما الذي نقوم به مقاتله حزب
العمال من الذين يقاتلونهم ليس هنالك اي
القوات من داعش متبقيه في تلك المنطقه لا
تحاوله ان تستخدمه هذا الامر كذريع ضد
تركيا خسرت جنودها في محاربه داعش
سيد الين لان الوقت دهمنا سيد عائدين دعني
اسمع من السيد علي السيد قال يعني تركيا
عضو في حلف الناتو وحليف استراتيجي
للولايات المتحده او شريك استراتيجي
للولايات المتحده امنها مهدد كما يقول
السيد ايضا فما الذي تفعله الولايات
المتحده
انا لا اوافق على كلامي السفير السابق على
ان قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تقوم بقص في
المدن التركيه مع حدث في اسطنبول في
الثالث عشر من نوفمبر عندما حصل ذلك
الهجوم الارهابي المروع
باثاره من الولايات المتحده واعتقدوا انه
هنالك الكثير من الاسئله التي
اقترحت ان قوات حمايه الشعب الكليه قد
تكون متواطئه قوات حمايه الشعب الكوريه لم
تكن من خريطه باي هجمات تستهدف الحدود
التركيه وايضا من الملتهما المتهمه كانت
هي عربيات دخلت من حدود تركيا عبر المناطق
المحتله انا لا اقول ان تركيا تفضل
يدافعوا عن سياده الاراضي السوريه حاليا
تركيا تحتل 400
1000 سيد اهلا شكرا للاسف كان السؤال عن
الدوري الامريكي اعلن مكوفسكي كبير
الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي والمختص
في الشؤون التركيه كنت معنا من واشنطن ومن
انقره اشكر السيد ايضا نورهان السفير
السابق في الخارجيه التركيه
[موسيقى]
نفت بجين تقرير البنتاجون الذي رشح زياده
مخزون الصين من الرؤوس الحربيه النوويه
باكثر من ثلاثه اضعاف بحلول عام
2035 وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
ان بلاده لا تسعى لخوض سباق تسلح النووي
وتؤكد احتفاظها بالحد الادنى المطلوب
لقواتها النوويه ضمن سياستها للامن القومي
وكانت واشنطن اعتبرت في وقت سابق ان الصين
هي اكبر متحدثا عسكريا تواجهه حاليا
الترسانه النوويه الصينيه بين الحقيقه
والتقديرات الامريكيه هل العالم على اعتاب
نظام نووي ثلاثي القطبيه بعد التقارير
الامريكيه التي تصف بالجين باكبر تحدي
عسكري تواجهه يحضر البنتاجون من وتيره
تطور الترسانه النوويه
الاخير لوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه امكانيه
بلوغ المخصون النووي الصيني نحو 2500 راس
النووي بحلول 2035 مضيفا ان المخزون
الحالي تخطى 400 راس ذكر التقرير باختبار
135 صاروخا قادرا على حمل رؤوس النووي
خلال عام 2021
كله تحديث في الجيش الصيني يحدث ازمه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تخفي
انزعاجها من التقدم الكبير لسلاح الجو
وتخشى التحاقه سريعا بالقوات جويه الغربيه
دفعت الصين عن سياستها بنفي الاتهامات
لامريكيه لها بالرغبه في دخول سباق التسلح
وقال المتحدث باسم خارجيتها جولي جون ان
السياسه بلاده للدفاع عن النفس مؤكدا
الالتزامها بعقيدتها العسكريه التي تنص
على عدم البدء باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه
بعد ثلاثه عقود من تلاش الكابوس النووي
للحرب البارده تزداد مخاوف واشنطن
المتبوعه بتحذيرات من سعيدين الى امتلاك
قوه النوويه عظمى حتى وان تحقق السيناريو
الاخير للبنت تبقى الصين بعيده عن منافسه
القوه النوويه الامريكيه فالسند الى تقرير
الوزاره التعليم الذي فرضه الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب بلغ المخزون النووي الامريكي
عام 2020 اكثر من ثلاثه الاف وسبع مئه راس
النووي مفعلا او غير حل وهذا العدد هو
الادنى منذ بلغ مخصوم هذا روته في اوجه
حرب البارده عام
1967 عندما كان اكثر من واحد وثلاثين الف
راس حربي
الاستراتيجيه الصينيه لبناء جيش عالمي
بحلول عام 2049 هي بنظره واشنطن مقدمه
لسباق النحو التسلح ثلاثي القطبيه سباق
كان على مد ثلاثه 73 عاما حكرا على روسيا
والولايات المتحده اعلان موسكو الاخير
بانها ستل اهتمام خاصه ببناء بنيه تحتيه
ترتبط بقوتها النوويه
يضاعف من مخاوف واشنطن التقليديه والجديده
الترسانه النوويه الصينيه المحتمله وفق
تقارير البنتاجون اليست ورقه ضغط مرتبطه
بالسياسه بيجين في المحيطين الهندي
انضموا الينا من فرجينيا وليم كجان مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق لشؤون
الترسانه النبويه سيد ويليام الصين تعتمد
سياسه الغموض النووي من اين اتت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بهذه الارقام
واتت من مصادر مفتوحه متوفره نصيب بشكل
اساسي تحاول ان يقوم يصلوا انفسهم الى الى
درجه يكون لديهم استراتيجيه شامله بالتالي
يقومون بالتخويف في اي طرف ممكن ليس هنالك
قضيه واحده انما يتعلق الامر على المحاك
عندما يتعلق الامر بالاسلحه النوويه لدى
اكنهم لديهم استراتيجيه شامله من اجل تحدي
ان النظام العالمي وهو بشكل اساسي تقوده
الولايات المتحده وبالاجل تحدي النظام
الدولي في مسالته حقي الملاحه وحقوق الصيد
وايضا التحديات الاقتصاديه في مساله التي
احتكار العملات وايضا لمصلحتها
وايضا
الملكيه الفكريه والتخويف باستخدامي جيشها
وبنائه
ورينا في ساحل الفلبين وماليزيا وهمم
وزعم انها جزء من اراضيها وجزء من سيادتها
كل هذا الامر هي مصمم لكي يكون لديها
طريقه كبيره مهمه وقويه من اجل تخويث في
اي قوه كبرى قد تقف امامها امام طموحات
ابي راينا هذه افضل طريقه لها لكي تكون
لديها استراتيجيه شامله بالتالي تمكينها
من الوقوف والتاثير او تخويف ومن همم
والحصول على التفوق على مستويات عديده
فيما يتعلق في تايوان
ولكن الصين تنفي وتقول بان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تضخم هذه الارقام للضغط
عليها
الكورتي وصلت كذلك لان
الموقف ليس العاب ليس له اي منطقه ليس
هناك لا يواجهون اي تهديد لماذا سيسعون
ذلك الصين تصعد في حاله الصعود اقتصادي
لديهم الفرصه لكي يكونوا شركاء متعاونين
مع العالم خاصه في المنطقه لكن ذلك وهم
يرغبون لهم اليد العليا في المنطقه التالي
لا يمكنهم ان
السلام عليكم
مساله تطوير الاسلحه النووي باي طريقه
اخرى طيب حتى لو اعتبرنا بان الصين تقوم
بذلك بحلول عام
2035 بحسب تقرير البنتاجون سيكون لدى
الصين
1500 راس نووي بينما تمتلك الولايات
المتحده اليوم ثلاثه الاف 1750 راس نووي
هل هو مسموح للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ان تتفوق بكل هذا العدد ولا يحق لدول اخرى
القيام بتطوير السلاح النووي
اعجبني
بشكل جيد
هذه بقايا الحرب البارده وهذه محاولات
لبقاء النظام الدولي من اجل رجعي الحرمانه
اسمعه من الطرف المقابل وب بشكل اساسي من
بقايا الحرب البارده الشيوعيه وما هذه
الامر ما زال موجوده في الصين لدينا مثلا
ومطامح نوويه مثلا مع مثل رئيس الجيه هو
ديكتاتور لمدى الحياه هذا
فيما يتعلقوا بالعالم
قضيه
وقد لا تسمح همم ليس لهم
بزياده نفوذه في العالم الاولاد المتحده
ان كانت هي في على طريقه
سنتها النوويه وليست زيادهها بمرور الوقت
سيد ويليام كيف سترد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على ما تعتبرونه تهديدا من قبل
الصين يعني دخلت في احلاف قامت بتحالفات
تقوم ايضا بوضع قيود على التجاره تعتبر
بان الصين مهدد اساسي لها مع ذلك الارقام
تشير بحسب البنتاجون بانها تطور اسلحتها
فما الذي ستفعله الولايات المتحده اكثر
كما قلت هي هنالك خطه شامله للصين لكي
تتمكن من تخويف جيرانها وقد بدات مع
استراليا واليابان وايضا استخدام همم
الحرب الوكاله عن طريق كوريا الشماليه عن
الولايات المتحده ما الذي ستقوم به
مش باعرف
يكون بيوقفها بشكل حاسم وصارم والتزام
بالاتفاقيات الدوليه التي تمنع انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه وسنقوم بهذا الامر بشكل
واضح وصارم شكرا لك المساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي السابق لشؤون الترسانه النوويه
كنت معنا من فرجينيا
رئيس مركز الصين ولا عولمه لكن تعذر ذلك
في اللحظات الاخيره
قال المبعوث الامريكي الخاص لايران روبرت
مالي ان الدبلوماسيه خيار واشنطن الاول
لمنع طهران من امتلاك سلاح النووي واضاف
في مقابله مع موقع فرن بوليسيه ان الخيار
العسكري لا يزال على الطاوله كخيار اخير
في حال فشل العقوبات والدبلوماسيه
دبلوماسيه انها الطريقه الافضل والاكثر
استدامه لمنع ايران من امتلاك سلاح النووي
ولا تزال الدبلوماسيه خيارنا الافضل وانا
اقوم باستخدام خيارات اخرى من بينها الضغط
الدولي الذي لم تختبره ايران لسنوات عديده
فلدينا العقوبات والضغوط الدبلوماسيه واذا
لم تنجح اي من تلك الادوات قال الرئيس انه
قد يوافق على الخيار العسكري كخيار الاخير
لكننا لم نصل الى تلك المرحله وما زلنا
نامل ان نجد وسائل اخرى وان تغير ايران
مسارها الحالي
افاد مراسل الجزيره نقلا عن مسؤول حكوميه
افغاني بمقتل 23 شخصا واصابه اكثر من 30
اخرين في تفجير داخل مدرسه دينيه في ولايه
سمين شمالي البلاد وقال مراسلنا نقلا عن
المسؤول الحكومي ان الحكومه او القوات
الافغانيه طوقت المنطقه التي وقع فيها
التفجير في مدينه ايفك هذا ولم تعلن اي
جهه مسؤوليتها عن التفسير
افادت وكاله رويترز بمقتل زعيم تنظيم
الدوله ابو الحسن الهاشمي القرشي ونقلت
رويترز عن متحدثا باسم التنظيم قوي انه تم
تعيينه زعيم جديد يدعى ابو الحسين الحسيني
القرش من اجلتها قالت القياده الوسط
الامريكيه ان مقتل زعيم تنظيم الدوله في
منتصف اكتوبر الماضي هو ضربه اخرى لتنظيمه
واضافات ان الجيش السوري الحرشه من
العمليه التي ادت الى مقتل زعيم التنظيم
في درعا من سوريا منتصفه اكتوبر المنطقه
استشهد شاب فلسطيني واصيب اخر برصاص قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي اقتحمت بلده
يعبد جنوب غربي مدينه جنين بالضفه الغربيه
كما اعتقلت قوه الاحتلال الاسير المحرر
عبد الغني حرز الله بعد محاصره منزله في
البلده واداله اشتباكات المسلحه مع
مقاومين فلسطينيين خرجوا للتصدي للقوات
الاسرائيليه
وصل زعيم حزب اللكود بنيامين نتنياهو
مشاورات لتشكيل الحكومه وافادت القناه
الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه ان المفاوضات مع
حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه بزعمتي يتقيل سموتش
احرز التقدما ملحوضا واضافه القناه
الماليه بالتناوب مع اريداي زعيم حركته
شاس للمتدينين الشرقيين لمده عامين يتولى
بعدها حقيبه الداخليه ولم يتضح بعد موعد
التوقيع على الاتفاق الائتلافيه مع رسومات
ريتش الذي نجح وفقه وسائل الاعلام
اسرائيليه في اقناعه بتكليفه بالاشراف على
الاداره المدنيه في الضفه الغربيه ونقل
الصلاحيات من وزاره الدفاع اليه
[موسيقى]
اختراق علمي كبير هكذا يتم الحديث عن
اعلان شركه ايسايل يابانيه لصناعه الادويه
وشركاتها الامريكيه بيوتين الشركتان
ابتكرتان عقارا تجريبيا لمرض الزهايمر حيث
هو ذكرتها انه ابطا من تطور المرض في
تجربه كبيره شملت عددا من المراه
يعد العقار التجريبي الرائد لمرض الزهايمر
المسمى لكلمه نقله طبيه كبيره ان عاشت
الامال في تغيير مسارح علاج المرض لدى
ملايين المرضى وقد اعرب علماء عن ارتياحهم
من النتائج الكامله للمرحله الثالثه من
التجارب السريريه التي بداوها قبل عام
ونصف وشامله الفا 1800 من مرضى الزهايمر
في مراحل مبكره من الاصابه فقد اظهرت
نتائج انخفاضا بنسبه
27% من التدهور الادراكي لدى المرضى الذين
تلقوا العلاج بعقار لكلمه وتتخذ الشركتان
المصنعتان للعقارب التجريبي اجراءات
الحصول على ترخيص هذا الدواء الجديد
للاستعمال في امريكا واوروبا واليابان
يقول كبير الباحثين في شركه ايسايل
اليابانيه المصنعه للعقار ان اهميته تكمن
في كونه صمم للقضاء على بروتينات ايميلات
بيتا السامه التي تتسرب في الدماغ وتسبب
الاصابه بمرض الزهايمر
[موسيقى]
قيد المراجعه من قبل اداره الغذاء والدواء
الامريكيه للحصول على موافقه سريعه بموجب
قانون رسوم متعه الادويه الموصوفه لذلك
نحن قريبون الان من هذا التاريخ
الاطباء منقسمون حول مدى الاختلاف الذي قد
تحدثه هذه التغييرات للمرضى والاسر فقد
اظهرت النتائج ان العقارات قد يؤدي الى
اثار جانبيه من بينها التورم والنزيف في
الدماغ فيما تدرس اداره الغذاء والدواء في
الولايات المتحده الموافقه المعجله على
العقار ومن المتوقع ان يتخذ القرار في
اوائل يناير واذا تمت الموافقه عليه
فسيكون الثانيه عقار مضاد للاميلاج في
السوق جميع العلاجات المتاحه لسته ملايين
امريكي مصابين بمرض الزهايمر وملايين في
جميع انحاء العالم تخفف الاعراض مؤقتا فقط
لذا يعد النجاح الذي يمكن ان يحققه هذا
العلاج حاجه ملحها بعد خيبات الامل
المتكرره في البحث عن علاجات افضل
ضرب الزعيمر
[موسيقى]
ولكن لماذا يعد الامر كشفا علميا مهما
الدواء الجديد يعمل على ابطاء تدمير خلايا
الدماغ هو اختراق بحثي ينهي عقودا من
الفشل ويظهر ان حقبه جديده من الادويه
لعلاج مرض الزهايمر بدات كيف ذلك العقار
عباره عن جسم مضاد مثل تلك التي يصنعها
الجسم لمهاجمه الفيروسات او البكتيريا او
البكتيريا تم تصميمه لاخبار جهاز المناعي
بازاله البروتين معين من الدماغ يحتلها
هذا البروتين فراغات هذه الفراغات تشكل
لويحات او فواصل وهو ما يعد الثمن اهم
لمرض الزهايمر شملت التجربه واسعه النطاق
متطوعا يعانون من المرض في مراحلها
المبكره وتم اعطاء من العقار كل اسبوعين
يعاني حاليا اكثر من 55 مليون شخص في
العالم من الازهايمر ومن المتوقع ان
يتجاوز عدد المصابين به 100 و 139 مليون
بحلول عام
2050 الفكره الكامله لابطاء تدمير الدماغ
في مرض الزهايمر بدات قبل 30 عاما وكان
وراءها البروفيسور جون هاردي احد الباحثين
الرائدين في العالم قد شهدت السنوات
الاربعه الماضيه خطوات بعثت الامل لدى
المصابين بمرض الزهايمر كان من ابرازها
ابتكاري ودواء جديد واجراء فحوص للدم
لاكتشافه المرض مبكرا فضلا عن تصميم قريه
متخصصه تساعد المرضى في الحفاظ على حياتهم
الطبيعيه ماذا جرى في العام الماضي في
العام الماضي اعتمدت اداره الغذاء والدواء
اشتركيه عقار ادور كانو ماب لعلاج بعض
حالات الالسايمر شرط اجراء مزيد من
الدراسات لتاكيد فوائده كما يحتاج الخبراء
كذلك الى تحديد المرضى الذين يمكنهم
الاستفاده من العقاري
دراسات حديثه اظهرت ان مثبطات نشاط
الانزيمات ترتبت عليها اثار جانبيه كبيره
لدى مرضى الزهايمر الخفيف والمتوسط مما
ادى لتراجع الحماس نحو اليتي عملي هذا
الدواء ينضم الينا من بيروت الدكتور نبيل
نجا اخصائيه طب الاعصاب وامراض الشيخوخه
اهلا بك دكتور بشكل بسيط اشرح لنا كيف
يعمل هذا العقار الجديد بشكل مبسط
مثل ما ذكر بالتقرير حضرتك
ذكرتيه في عنا مواد مضره بالدماغ اسمها
بالتعميله هل مواد عندما تتجمع في اماكن
معينه في الدماغ تقضي على الخلايا العصبيه
وبالتالي تقضي على الوظائف المسؤول عنها
المسؤوله عنها هذه الخلايا
واول العوارض هي الذاكره القريبه المدى في
اماكن معينه من الدماغ هذا العقار همم فتح
نافذه امل جديده لان العقارات السابقه
كانت تعمل فقط على الناقلات العصبيه في
الدماغ نيوروت رسمترس والتي كانت تخفف من
بعض العوارض ولكن لا تاخر المرض كثيرا
تبطئ من تطوره هذا العقار الجديد منع تجمع
هذه البروتينات المضره التي تعرف
بالبتعملويد منعها ان تشكل صف لان هذه
البروتينات اذا لم تتجمع مع بعضها ما
بتشكل خطر كبير على الدماغ فاذا هي عندما
تتجمع تشكل خطر هذا العقار الذي خرق كل
الفشل الذي دام 30 سنه تقريبا في ابحاث
علاج مرض الازايمر همم اكد انه بتقنيه
جديده هي تعتبر في بعض اللقاحات اللي مثل
ما ذكرت حضرتك همم بالتقرير الانتي بوديز
يعني وكانه همم هو عميقاوم جسم غريب دخل
عليه مثل همم مقاومه الفيروسات فاذا هذا
هو الخرق الذي همم همم
بين هذا العقار والعقارات السابقه ولكن
ماذا عن الاثار الجانبيه هل تم تجاوزها في
هذا العقار الجديد
لا لم يتم تجاوزها بعد يعني ما زال هناك
همم
خوف من هذه الاثار الجانبيه همم
ممكن ان تصل الى حد النزيف في الدماغ
بنسبه 18% يعني بالمجموعه ال 1795 مريض
اللي اجريت عليهم الابحاث 18% همم من اللي
اخذوا العقار نصابه بنزف دماغي فاذا هذه
النسبه همم من همم نسبه خفيفه ولذلك علينا
الانتظار اكثر ولكن لانه لم يكن هناك اي
عقار جديد لذلك الاف دي اي او منظمه
التغذيه والصحه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه استعجلت في اعطاء هذا العقار
الجديد همم الاذن باخذه من قبل المرضى
ولكن بشروط معينه ويجب على المريض ان يخضع
الى فحوصات ده فحوصات اشعه ودم بكلمه
واحده لو سمحت باي مرحله يمكن استخدامها
هذا العقار
في المراحل الاولى هذا هو همم يعني الاف
دي اي اللي اكدت عليه انه في مراحل الاولى
من المرض ان اما في المراحل المتقدمه له
دكتور نبيل لا نجى اخصائي طب الاعصاب
وامراض الشيخوخه شكرا لك
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه نقترب
اليها بعد
لحظات او اقتربنا اليه بالفعل وهذا موعدنا
مع موجز لاهم الانباء قبل الانتقال الى
الجوله الرياضيه يوميات الماضيه
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو
بلينكن ان الرئيس الروسي دمر ثلث البنيه
الاساسيه في اوكرانيا واضاف ان حلف شمال
الاطلسي عازما على تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا
مهما تتطلب الامر
في المقابل قالت موسكو ان الغربه يستخدم
امكانيات البنيه التحتيه الفضائيه المدنيه
لدعم العمليات العسكريه الاوكرانيه بجانب
اخر اقترحت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
مصادره الاصول الروسيه المجمده لتمويل
اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا
من جانبها قالت خارجات الروسيه ان موسكو
ستتخذ ما وصفتها باجراءات مناسبه اذا تعلق
الامر بمصادره اصولها في الاتحاد الاوروبي
اكد مصدر الرسمي تركيه للجزيره اكتمال
تحضيرات لعمليه عسكريه بريه تركيه شمالي
سوريا وقال ان العمليه لن تهدد القوات
الامريكيه والروسيه واكد رفض انقره
الانتشار الشكلي لقوات النظام السوري في
مناطق ما تعرف بقوه سوريا
من جهه اخرى قال المتحدث باسم البنتاجون
باتريك رايدر ان واشنطن تقر بمخاوف تركيا
الامريكيه المشروعه بشان الاعمال
الارهابيه على اراضيها وحضر في الوقت نفسه
من ان اجتياح البريا تركيا في تلك المنطقه
سيعدد ماء انجز في محاربه تنظيم الدوله
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه البنتاجون انه من
المرجح يزيد مخزون الصين من الرؤوس
الحربيه النوويه باكثر من ثلاثه اضعاف
خلال العقد المقبل وحذرات تقرير للجيش
الامريكي من ان عدد رؤوس الصين النوويه قد
يصل الى 1500 راس نووي بحلول عام 2035
في المقابل نفت بالجينز عليها لخوض سباق
تسلح النووي واكدت التزامها بعدم البدء
باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه
في المقابل قالت موسكو انها ستولي اهتماما
خاصا باقامه بنيه تحتيه ترتبط بقوتها
النوويه ونقلت وكاله تاسع عن وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه الافراد قوله انه من
الضروري تجنب اي مواجهه عسكريه بين القوه
النوويه
نهايه الحصاد تصبحون على الف خير
[موسيقى]